c
eni tout le monde je dis bien tout le
monde peut réaliser un clip musical mais
surtout quand on connaît quelques
astuces et je suis sûr que vous voulez
que je vous montre après l'intro
et salut à tous les gens c'est françois
pour la chaîne expliquer encore et il ya
quelques semaines j'étais sur le
tournage d'un clip pour un groupe et je
me suis dis franchement c'est vraiment
pas très compliqué de faire un clip
enfin quand on sait par quel bout le
prendre et du coup je me suis dit que
j'allais vous partagez une astuce pour
gagner un temps monumental dans le
montage de genre de projet avec final
cut et franchement quand je vois comment
c'est facile et le temps que j'ai passé
à monter tout ça à la main peu les
boules là allez allez c'est parti
et hop on y va alors pour tourner un
clip généralement on va faire tourner
plusieurs fois les musiciens sur une
bonne enregistré autant de fois que
nécessaire donc a pas forcément besoin
d'avoir dix caméras qui filment en même
temps il suffit juste de répéter
l'opération et moi c'est ce que j'ai
fait j'avais seulement deux caméras et
au passage si vous vous rappelez vous
prenez une petite vidéo qui vous montre
que vous pouvez aussi le faire hein
juste avec un smartphone et un
stabilisateur pouvoir ça vous pouvez
cliquer sur le lien qui s'affiche sur
votre écran ah oui et le truc impératif
vous allez comprendre pourquoi après ces
deux films et avec le son du boîtier
activé il faut surtout avoir le son
quand vous allez faire vos plans même si
le son est dégueulasse en sortie de
boîtiers et que c'est pas du tout
quelque chose qui nous intéresse pour
absolument le garder actif
vous allez comprendre après pourquoi
alors une fois qu'on a importé tous nos
ruches ici dans final cut moi je me suis
fait un petit dossier multicam on va
venir
les sélectionnés tous avec un petit
commandes à et on va faire un clic droit
dessus et dans le menu on va cliquez sur
nouveau plan multicanaux et surtout dans
le lot on n'oublie pas de mettre le
fichier audio qui va servir pour la
bande son du clip alors on va l'appeler
plan multicam 2 puisque j'en ai déjà un
hockey et là on va attendre un petit peu
que final cut fasse sa petite tambouille
vous allez voir c'est juste de la balle
mais de la balle complet alors voilà
j'ai mon plan multicam ici je vais venir
tout simplement le glisser ici dans la
timeline
mais là où ça va être fun c'est si je
clique sur le plan ici je me retrouve
avec tous les plans que j'ai tourné même
des plantes partiel est ici le fichier
sont ici le truc méga cool c'est que
final cut ma synchronisée absolument
tous les plains il m'a synchroniser tous
l'audio le truc qui me prenait des
heures à faire pour être sûr de
rattraper de machins et puis quand il y
avait des plans qui faisait pas la
langue
hornus clip il fallait les remettre
dedans c'était juste une horreur la même
des plantes partiel comme celui là ici
eh ben il sent synchronisée ça veut donc
dire que vous n'aurez pas à synchroniser
quoi que ce soit sur les différents
plans vous pouvez en avoir autant que
vous voulez il ya tout qui se fait tout
seul comme par magie c'est juste geste
fou et c'est pas fini et c'est pas fini
parce que bon c'est plein c'est bien ils
sont synchronisés mais si je lance ici
mon clip
ben là et j'ai qu'un seul plongée que le
plan du départ je vais couper le son
pour pas vous pour lui avec sa derrière
alors maintenant je vais aller dans une
présentation d'en afficher dans le
visualiseur est ici cliquez sur angles
ou shift commandes set up alors la ferme
et stoke ne nous intéresse plus
maintenant ce que je vais faire c'est me
caler ici sur la bande son est bien
cliqué sur cette icône ua qui va
indiquer à final cut que je veux
simplement changer l'image égard des
leçons de la première piste et là ça va
juste être
ouf c'est à dire que je vais lancer ici
on tape un sur espace mon plan qui est
noir forcément puisqu'il ya uniquement
le son est à chaque fois que j'ai
vouloir changer d'angle
je vais cliquez sur l'image qui
m'intéressent la geôle abbas
ici je veux le batteur ici je veux la
chanteuse ici un peu de guitare la tête
du guitariste et c'est tout c'est à dire
que ici je vais avoir des découpes qui
vont être faites avec les changements
d'angle alors l'idéal c'est de le faire
en fonction du tempo en fonction du
rythme en direct mais je vais pouvoir
également ici derrière si ça me convient
pas si finalement je veux pas la guitare
ici mais je vais tout simplement up me
placer au début et prendre à notre plan
et il va me changer le plan comme ça je
peux aussi tout simplement élaguer des
plans passé sur un autre qui joue que
celui ci soit + lomb je vais pouvoir
l'élaguer ici j'étais en fait je pouvoir
rattraper les petites imperfections du
fait du changement de caméra en live
l'idéal c'est de faire un découpage
grosso modo en live dans le rythme etc
et puis après derrière on va venir
peaufiner un petit peu on va venir
recalé sur les temps forts on va venir
changer des plans d'avenir en rajouter
d'autres si on veut et puis c'est tout
et c'est juste magique quoi c'est ça m'a
fait halluciner je me demandais comment
j'ai pu faire avant ça
et voilà les amis maintenant à vous de
monter vos propres clips
j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura aidé
vous aura appris des choses si c'est le
cas n'hésitez pas à mettre le
traditionnel coup de blaster sur le
pouce en l'air qui se situe en dessous
de cette vidéo pensez à vous abonner à
partager la vidéo toussa toussa toussa
et nous on se retrouve très vite pour
une nouvelle vidéo mais en attendant
rester curieux
[Musique]